eww
[musique]
Pouah
eww
[musique]
5w
pouah 5
eww
eww que
ça devrait l'être aussi
[musique]
eww
courtiser 5
[musique]
Pouah
5w
pouah pouah
[musique]
Dès que j’ai appris la nouvelle, j’ai su que j’en avais besoin.
Euh, maintenant je suis en train de revoir la partie plan
Parce que l'exigence est simplement d'introduire du GNL, alors la température ne sera jamais
Vous pouvez régler le son afin qu'il ne monte ou ne descende pas.
Avec cette grande quantité de réfrigérant lui-même très faible, que faire dans cette grande quantité comme cette fois
Le stockage en vrac nécessite des températures stables
[musique]
Vous entendrez tous les préparatifs pour accueillir le peuple
Envoyez tous les Bonghamun existants, y compris le maquereau, et saluez le 110e.
Prêt à partir
[musique]
eww